all right we're gonna get started
so good morning everyone or i guess um
good morning where i'm sitting
um uh i think for for where most of
for where most of you are sitting it's
probably it's probably a good
um so thanks for joining me at the end
of the day here
um this is navigating microservices
with.net core
and tai so if you're here for a
different talk you're in the wrong room
um so physically get up and move
yourself to another room
just kidding so we'll get started
so a little bit about me uh i'm
i've worked on asp.net core for many
many years as architect and developer
mvc routing client factory health checks
razor blazer and something new called
project high
which we'll be talking about in quite a
lot of detail today
and so that's that's normally how i
would introduce myself
except uh as of about a month ago i'm
part of the azure incubations team so
this is probably my last conference talk
ever uh representing the.net core team
which is a
sort of a bittersweet uh bitter sweet
end and a bittersweet farewell but it's
been a
it's been an awesome journey doing decor
and asp.net core and
i'll always holds i'll always hold that
in my heart
um so what are we going to do today
we're going to talk about your developer
productivity
um and specifically i'm speaking to
developer productivity for you building
services
building back ends building
microservices and i don't really care if
you
like to use the term microservices to
describe what you're doing
i don't think it matters that much if
you feel like you're really doing
microservices or you're just building
modern backend and modern
web sorts of applications the truth is
that really like every application is a
multi-tier application
every application these days has got
multiple multiple components to it and
multiple layers to it
and it's very rare that we're actually
building applications that are just one
component these days
if you're there like you're lucky
because you're
you're developing your development
process probably pretty simple
so we're going to talk about how to
accelerate your productivity
um with the focus being on a new tool
that we're building called on a tie
and how you can become more productive
and more successful by trying to make
development more
like production and we'll show how you
can easily containerize and deploy.net
core services
so a little bit about dot-net tie we're
going to jump in
with a lot of demos by the way pretty
much right away
so a little bit about donna tai what
we're referring to
as a public experiment for dot-net five
um we'll talk a little bit about what
that means but
it basically means that we're we're
building creating and innovating on a
tool in the open
on github with the community um that
sort of has an unclear destination we're
just trying to build some cool tech
we're trying to learn as much as we can
along the way um
and we'll talk a little bit more about
what that means in the future and it's
a.net core focus cloud development tool
focusing probably on your local
development but also a little bit on
sort of deployment publishing in your
overall
microservices workflow and if you
haven't checked it out already you can
find it on github
hopefully what you're going to see today
is going to wet your whistle a little
bit and make you
make you interested to go look at that
and tell us what you think
so with that i'm going to i'm going to
drop doubt of the slides
new personal best of three minutes
slides and
we're just going to go right into some
demos here
so i've got my terminal here
and i'm going to load up the first demo
and where better to start
with demos than a sort of hello world
kind of application really simple little
thing
and we're really going to get to the
essence here
of what it means to do to do
microservices development or to do
multi-service development
so i've got a front-end project and i've
got a back-end project and i've got
a.net i've got them in a.net solution
here
using vs code by the way if you haven't
figured that out
and i'll just show you all the code in
these projects there's a really small
amount of code here
and there's absolutely nothing tricky
going on um
so here's here's a front-end project
it's got no dependencies other than
asp.net core
and here's my back-end project it's got
no dependencies other than asp.net core
and it's got a program cs and it's got a
startup cs and
configuration and other than that there
is nothing going on
so let's take a look at the code and i'm
trying to build basically the simplest
thing that gets to the essence of what
you're doing if you're doing
microservices over http
or just you know web app and api tier
style development
so i've got the standard boilerplate
startup cs
i've got adjacent serializer options and
i've got one little endpoint here and
i'm just going to respond to the root
url
and i'm going to respond with some
information about myself
so what is my um what is my local ip
address
what is my local host name and what is
my content type and serialized adjacent
to the response
that's the backend app and my frontend
app
we'll take a look there and in my
frontend app i've got
health checks and i've got i've got one
endpoint here
i'm going to respond to the root url and
i'm going to do some service to service
communication
so i'm going to do i'm going to do sort
of the first most basic thing here
i'm going to get an http client and i'm
going to call into my back end api
and i've got a little helper method here
to get the back end get the uri of the
backend service
and then i'll deserialize the json and
i'm going to print out basically the
same information for myself so
where is my back end i p address what is
my back end host name so
just demonstrating really that i can
communicate between these two services
so let's we're really doing fundamentals
here but if i wanted to run these two
projects like what would i do
think about what you would do if you'd
run these projects
if you're in vs code you might open two
terminals
and launch two projects at two terminals
i have heard legend
tell that it's possible to write a
launch config for vs code
that will launch them um that will
launch them in
both at the same time some people i know
would open like two vs code windows
the other thing that you could do if
you're in visual studio
is that you could use visual studio to
configure a multi
a multi-project launch which is kind of
a kind of hidden in the menus but it
seems to work pretty well and you can
get an experience where you launch
multiple projects but i guess what i
want to impress upon you is that most of
our solutions
most of our tools and technologies that
we use today are really oriented around
the idea of
running one thing at a time but when we
do microservices development or we do
multi-service development in general
we're really talking about running
multiple things at a time
the other thing that i would mention is
if i'm doing this in vs code
i will get a port conflict in vs code by
default
by default these services are both going
to want to use port 5000
and that's going to conflict in vs code
and it's going to cause a problem
now in visual studio by default again
you would get different ports because
iis would use different ports by default
but maybe you're not using visual studio
maybe you're not even on windows
maybe you're not using iis in production
and so you're not using iis as part of
your development
all these factors come into play and you
have to play this game of
how do i choose ports that i can
remember that don't conflict with each
other
so that i can launch my apps at the same
time and everything can work in harmony
so we're now to the first thing that ty
can do for you
and let's let's go ahead and run some
code sorry my prompt is
taking over the world so we'll do a tie
run
and i'm in the same directory as my
front-end back-end solution
and so over here we can see loads
application details launches tie host
runs a dashboard builds projects and
then there's a whole bunch of spew which
you can probably ignore
if i click that link that's this link
right here
it's the thai dashboard the dashboard is
always going to launch on a predictable
port
and what i can see when i come to the
dashboard right away is
well it's got a list of services it's
got my front end my back end
where they came from um what urls
they're listening on
replicas restarts and logs so it's
pretty cool so this is like
you should sort of think of this like
your developer console for multi-service
development
you need a you need a sort of status
dashboard or sort of like
here's the state of what's going on
let's
let's go ahead and try this let's try my
back-end service and see if that's
working so just open that url
and you can see that we got a response
from the backend service this is my
my host name where i'm sat and then
let's try the front end project
and uh oh so the front end project is
crashing um because the
request uri must be an absolute uri or
base
address must be set i've done a lot with
http client but i'm not really sure what
that means
so um i think what i want to do is debug
and so i'm going to come back over here
and i'm going to do tie run again but
this time i'm going to say debug
and i'm going to add front end this is
confusing me front end there
so now what it's going to do um is it's
going to
do tie run again and it's going to
launch the processes but it's going to
halt the front end process from starting
so if we did open the dashboard and we
did try to visit this
visit this app via its http url it would
just block
effectively because we've injected code
into the process that's going to trigger
basically a weight loop and it's just
going to wait for a debugger to attach
so this is a nice way to be able to get
your startup errors and things like that
when you're doing a multi-process launch
which is a nice little convenience
so if i come over here and i say attach
you can see i've got my back-end and
front-end
processes running if i choose front-end
it's going to tell me everything about
all the symbols and every dll that's
ever
existed thanks um and i'm right here at
my get back in
uri call let's make sure that that's
working oh it's null
okay so that's the problem so i'm not
getting the uri of my back end and i
know i lied to you i tricked you that
was mean
i said that we would be able to get the
uri of the back end but we can't
actually do it
let's take a look at the implementation
of this function yeah
sorry i've got a i've got a to do here
that i didn't quite address and somebody
let that through code review
so we need to now know if we're going to
do service to service communication
we now need to know how we're going to
get the uri of that other service
and it's not really as straightforward
as it sounds
because maybe the uri of your other
service is going to be different in
development from production from staging
from
you know your machine from the way your
friend likes to debug
and it could be it could be different
right it could be subtle and there could
be lots of complexity
to it so i have a sort of
you know thought in my brain that as a
developer
as an engineer we like to solve problems
and we like to build
conventions and solutions about how to
solve problems so
one of the things that i might do or i
think that you might do if you needed to
solve this problem is you might say
well i'll use environment variables i'll
use environment variables to pass in the
host name
and the port and the protocol and things
like that and then i can build a url
from those things or you might choose to
use an environment variable to pass it
all
in one so i'm going to take a stab at
that
so let's say i use some environment
variables here
and i'm going to read these environment
variables and i'm going to combine them
into uri
and then i'll log the results so let's
give this try
tyron again
let's bring up our dashboard
so everything seems to have started
everything seems to have been working
let's give this a try
and it worked so we got the front end
and listening ip we got the
we got the host name of ourselves we got
the listening ip and hostname of the
backend
and they're the same but the fact that i
can print this out proves that
i actually did call through to the back
end and get that information
if we come to the dashboard and look at
the logs you can see that we've actually
logged the back end url so we did get
the back end url and environment
variables and we did
feed it out into these logs so that's
working
but this is still kind of this is still
kind of grunge
um compared to what i'd really like to
do so
you know if we're asp.net developers uh
one of the things that we have that's
really nice is configuration
right a bunch of different sources of
data feed into configuration
including environment variables by
default could be json files could be
environment variables could be command
line flags it could be
lots of things it's extensible so can we
leverage
configuration to do the same thing and
spoilers yes um so the reason why i
chose these particular environment
variables is that
these particular environment variables
map to
some configuration keys so it's not a
mistake not a typo
double underscore for kind of bizarre
reasons
that you can ask me about later if you
want maps
the configuration key separator so if i
wanted to
i could replace that with this and so i
could say
get get the service node from
configuration get the back end node from
configuration and get the protocol node
from configuration
and that's like if this
you know it's like if i used this
configuration style and so on right
it those separators those colons there
represent
a nested configuration structure like
you would see in json
so if you were code reviewing this i
hope i hope you would say this if you're
code reviewing this maybe you would
maybe you wouldn't
um but if you're code reviewing this you
might say you know
that's kind of messy and it really seems
like this code could be extracted
into a library or into helper method
so that we don't end up with 50
different versions of this code copy
pasted
really the only thing you care about
is diff is this and if you've got a lot
of services and you've got a lot of
different touch points of communication
you're going to have a lot of versions
of this code copy paste it around right
so let's do that let's write a little
helper method for it
and i i will tell you that we have
written that helper method for you
and the reason why it's not showing up
is that we've shipped it in a nuget
package
so if i come over here to my project
file i can add this
package microsoft tie extensions
configuration
save and then any moment now
there we go and we should be
okay yeah good job vs code
um so let me jump to this and i will
tell you that this is
this is basically the code um this is
basically the code that is in
that uh in that block that i showed you
before
and this is like the world's smallest
nuget library it's not literally the
world's smallest but it you get a
it's got one type and it's got two
methods in it and we've got
additional we've got an overload of get
service uri we've got an additional
overload of get connection string
and these are all ties opinions about
how to get data from one service to
another we call this service discovery
ty's opinions about how to do service
discovery
are that we set environment variables
those environment variables follow a
predictable convention
and those environment variables can flow
into configuration so that you can query
them
using anything that has access to
configuration which is pretty cool
and there's no trickery this looks like
and really sort of feels like to me a
convention that somebody else would
design
so if you decide you don't want to do it
this way you could do something
different but
having a built-in convention helps us
and makes us really productive
so if we walk through what we've seen
the fact that we have these two projects
in the same solution
means that thai will generate
environment variables when it runs them
inject them into each process so that
the processes can know how to find each
other
those environment variables get read
into configuration
using the built-in sort of defaults of
asp.net core configuration
and then you can use this helper method
to query them but at the end of the day
it's just
environment variables and configuration
there's nothing really tricky
or magical happening here it's just
because they're all part of the same
they're all part of the same thing so
um let's see something else that's kind
of interesting about
this and that's that's the question of
like well i said
let's make production let's make
development like production
one of the ways that we can help make
is giving you access to your production
tools in development
and giving you patterns that encourage
flexibility
so that you can you can leverage all
that so one thing i want to highlight
that i think i forgot to highlight
before
is if we look at the dashboard you can
see that these ports
are auto assigned right
these are these are you'll notice that
they're sequential you won't find these
hard-coded anywhere in the code
tai is assigning these ports and handing
them off to asp.net and saying hey
please use these ports to run on and
that's not a mistake it's on purpose
there there is you can configure that
and you can use uh specified ports if
you want to
but maybe your production system needs
to assign them for you
or maybe you routinely use different
ports in dev than you do in production
we're trying to encourage you to do more
portable things and more flexible things
so that you know your application is
going to work the first time that you
run in production
so to that end let's do something let's
let's show off something else that we
can do and i'm going to massage
these windows a little bit so that my
beautiful face is not covering up my
command prompt there we go
so i'm going to do tie run dash
docker which i guess is going to be just
shocking
so can we can we just run these in
docker
just as one of my favorite software
words why don't you just do that
can we just run these in docker
and you can see there's lots of docker
things that are happening here
let's take a look uh appears we can
just run these in docker so instead of
our projects now
we used to see projects here now we see
containers and we see a base image
let's give it a try so that's our back
end
and that's our front end and with our
front end
we've got a different listening ip and
we've got a different hostname
and we've got a different listening ip
and a different host name for our
backend
let's check out one more thing docker ps
which if you're a docker head not a
docker head list
list running containers like psax but
for docker
and you can see that we've got container
ids images
done at front-end dll done at back-end
dll that's our code
so my hypothesis here these container
ids
this one's 106 8 this one's d366
they show up here because inside the
container
that's what the operating system says
the hostname is
so inside the container the operating
system says the hostname is this
we're reporting that in our code and
it's flowing all the way out
now i would remind you that we don't
have any docker files we haven't done
anything to do docker here
we just ran stuff in docker which i
think is pretty neat
and we don't lose the ability to do
things like c
logs because we're running in docker and
you can see some of those environment
variables there
one more little trick here that i think
is kind of cool we'll
shut this down i'm gonna do a
tie run again and show off one more
little thing
um dashboard by the way is a blazer
server application
so you see the overlay of gray telling
you the the
process has gone away is a hallmark of a
blazer server application
that uh when something shuts down we
shut down a lot
one of the big enhancements that we're
working on and i'll come back to this
again in the future because i think it's
pretty important
we're working on a watch mode for tie so
that you can do thai run
and leave 15 services running and then
iterate on one of them
sort of while you're going and not have
to shut down everything
so let me bring get this window
and i'm going to shrink this down
so if i click on the name of a service
what it's going to take me to is the
metrics dashboard
and this is effectively done at counters
if you've seen donna counters a little
diagnostic command line tool to read
performance counter
like things this is done at counters
in a web ui so it's not a not a mistake
that we're using or not an accident that
we're using blazer server
you can see we've got two total requests
let's do let's do some more
let's do some more requests and just
prove that this is
that this is really happening so you can
see our number of total requests and
active requests per second is going up
as i spam the refresh button so we're
getting real counters it's really
happening
it's this is all really happening to us
so
let's let's try something else so we
were able to write an app that easily
runs locally
to sort of easily solve service
discovery and communication locally
what if we want and we could do the same
thing in docker because
we've written our app in a way that's
flexible about where it's running
um can we run it in kubernetes i'm gonna
check one thing because i think i failed
to clean up
after myself which is a sin um
let me cl just ex pretend that this is
not happening
um and i will clean up after myself
and then we'll get on with this
okay you can stop pretending that that
didn't happen
all right so let's see can we run this
in kubernetes
i'm going to do a tie deploy dash i
and dash i is for interactive the reason
being that i'm going to push this to a
real kubernetes cluster
running in azure so i need a container
registry to push the images to
i'm going to use my docker hub if you
have docker on your machine
i'm going to guess that you already have
a docker account i think they require
you to have one
it's a good little sort of scratch pad
place to push images and things that you
are experimenting with
or that don't have anything sensitive in
them but this could work with any
container registry that docker can use
we effectively just piggyback on top of
docker
so breaking this down for each service
so i entered the container registry for
each service
i compiled the service i published the
project i built a docker image
i pushed the docker image and i
generated manifest
and i've now got this running
in kubernetes so coupe ctl get pods is
like list the things that are running
there
and then by default things that are in
kubernetes are not going to be
accessible to the internet
so if i want to talk to it i'm going to
have to do a port forward
so i'll port forward the front end and
then this syntax
is local port to remote port i happen to
know that it's going to be listening on
port 80 because that's
like the most sensible thing so that's
what we do by default so local 5000
is now going to 80 in the cloud
and you can see i've got different
listening ips different host names and
so on
this front end with a horrible thing
after it this back end with a horrible
thing after it
these are the names of our pods so
inside the container inside the pod
that's what the operating system says
the hostname is and that's what we're
repeating
and these two services are able to
communicate with each other in the cloud
in kubernetes without us having to
really learn anything about kubernetes
without us having to hard code anything
and we're able to deploy them
without us writing any yaml so there's
actually no
yaml anywhere in here there's no
manifests or docker files or
arcane arcane anything that had to be
learned or had to be customized
so i think that's pretty cool i'm going
to go ahead and clean this up
tie undeploy is how you which i've i've
seen earlier but you all forgot about
tie on deploy is how you remove
something basically we tag the
kubernetes objects in a way that we can
associate them with the application
so that we can easily just sort of tear
it all down so whatever we
publish we can also unpublish so
i think that's pretty cool um let's talk
a little bit let's wrap up a little bit
about how this works
right and let's think about like what
goes into a docker file or what goes
into a kubernetes manifest
so typically what goes into a docker
file is
like well the base image right where are
you starting from
and your base image is usually going to
be something like the asp.net core base
image version 31
or asp.net core version two one or
dot-net core version three one or two
one if it's a worker or five-o hopefully
five-o
so like could we could we guess like
could we figure it out
and the answer is yeah we can figure it
out docker files for the most part or
boilerplate in the common case for
net because.net has a rich project
system
so we can look at this we can write
tools that look at this and say oh this
is a web project
we can write tools that look at this and
say
oh this is a 3-1 application so if you
think about like the docker tools in
visual studio
the docker tools in visual studio can
generate a templated docker file for you
the next evolution of generating a file
is to make the file go
away completely on the side of
kubernetes
i'm not going to assume that everybody
here knows kubernetes
but effectively what goes into a
kubernetes manifest
is um what port am i listening on what
image am i running things like that
just another layer higher than what goes
into a docker image
and the truth is that most of the time
there's a boilerplate not all the time
but most of the time they're boilerplate
so we can generate what you would want
for the common case
uh just sort of trivially and without
making too many assumptions we actually
haven't had too many feature requests
uh from people to try and add those
things so again because we're building a
dotnetfocus tool and we know about.net
and donna has a rich project system
we can sort of easily accelerate all
these things for you
and you can use them without having to
care about them or know about
them working of course we do have
options for things like using your own
docker file or customizing how that
works
customizing the base image we've had a
couple contributions on that from
community people which has been awesome
and like we do have those things but the
point is care about them when you need
to care about them
don't care about them for the common the
super common cases
i talked to a lot of people who say
things to me like
well nobody really knows how to use
docker here we know how to use the
command line but we don't really know
how to write docker files
and so the way that we use docker is
somebody who doesn't work here anymore
wrote a docker file a year ago and we've
copy pasted it into 100 different repos
right you don't really want to end up
there right
so you can choose to invest um we're
we're sort of on the line
of like well don't don't write something
down if it doesn't have any meaning
and most of the time for donut projects
dockerfile doesn't have a ton of meaning
so don't write it down
so uh one thing this is this is
admittedly
a very simple very fake kind of demo
right
um because we don't have any data stores
or any external dependencies it's just
your code
and like how many really truly useful
applications out there
have been written with just your code
usually you're going to have something
more sophisticated or some data stores
and things to talk to
and tai can do that too i wouldn't bring
it up if we couldn't it'd be
embarrassing
so let's take a look at more reasonable
bigger projects so i've got three.net
projects here
and they're in a.net solution and this
is a sample that i think docker
produced a long time ago and it is a
voting application where you can settle
the eternal question of which is best
cats and dogs and our architecture here
i'll just run through it
there's a there's a voting application
which is i think a razor pages
application
where it's going to put votes it's going
to take your vote and put it in redis
and then there's a worker that's going
to listen to that redis instance and
it's going to process your votes and put
them in
a postgres database and then there's a
results page that's going to display the
aggregate number of votes
so that we can really get to the bottom
of this important question
so we've got redis and we've got
postgres here and we've got our
lovely3.net projects
so let's go ahead and do a tie run
and see what happens
so i'll bring up the dashboard again
close some of these i always end up with
this like graveyard
of tabs when i do these demos so
something seems off
right away right we've got we've gotten
up to 20 restarts of the voting project
and um you can see there's an error i i
lovingly crafted this error message
need a connection string for postgresql
um the reason why this is failing
is that we haven't told anybody
how to configure where to get a
postgresql instance
we need to run one um but we don't have
one
so that's obviously a problem so if you
were if you were
living this life today what would you do
well you would install postgres on your
machine and run it
right or you would have a staging
instance in the cloud you would copy a
connection string and put it in user
secrets
or you might run if you're pretty savvy
you might run postgres in a container
but now you're orchestrating external
tools so i need to remember to docker
run my postgres
before i launch my application you might
build some tooling or some scripts
around that
well it's no surprise that like tai can
manage this for you too
because it's one of the most common
things that we have to deal with as
service developers
is where do my data where do my data
stores come from and how do i manage
their lifetimes
so let's do a tie init tie init
is a command that is going to just like
scaffold out for you a configuration
file
and tie does have a configuration file
uh the reason being that
it's not needed for cases like what we
saw before but it's really helpful when
your app
goes beyond like one or two projects or
one or two dependencies
and it's needed for dependencies in
general so you shouldn't be too scared
about it because
too scary tie init will
by the way tie a knit will scaffold for
you
what we would generate by default so
this is effectively what ti sees by
default if you just give
us a solution file or a directory
we do have a schema and we do have
schema validation and there is a bug
with it
and the bug has been fixed but not
published out to the version of the
schema that i'm using
so i am aware of these little squiggles
um
they're here to help um and there is
some there is some completion and things
like that for this file
as well but you shouldn't be too scared
about this because
it's not as complicated as something
like a helm chart if you've seen those
so going back to what we were doing we
were going to add
postgres and redis here so let's go
ahead and do that so here's my
here's my redis i've just got snippets
so you don't have to watch me remember
this
and let's talk through this so i'm
adding a service
to my list of services called redis
we're introducing some of the concepts
here right
all your projects or services now we
have a service that comes from an image
and this is just the docker image so
this is just the name of the docker
image yeah redis
and then something else that's cool
that's going on here is this binding
section
so the way that tai thinks about
bindings and the way that tai thinks
about
composition is that you have a list of
services
services have what we call bindings and
bindings are like here's what i have
right
so if you're redis you're saying here's
what i have
i have port 6379 where i'm going to be
listening for tcp
and i also have a connection string that
people
should use if they want to connect to me
and the way to sort of think about the
difference between like a uri
and a connection string is uris are
always uris they always have a port
uh or an optional port a protocol and a
like hostname
whereas connection strings are just text
so like your database has a password
it's probably not a uri right
your redis connection string might have
a password in this case it doesn't
because we haven't configured one
but it might just be arbitrary key value
pairs it's arbitrary text right
so the fact that we've declared redis
as part of this application and the fact
that we've declared a binding with a
connection string
as part of this application means
that inside my voting application
i can call
configuration.getconnectionstring
now this is a built-in in the box
asp.net core
method or microsoft extensions
configuration method
we're actually using the same
configuration or the same conventions
around connection strings
that you would get today if you scaffold
an asp.net core website with a sql
database
so it's not actually different than some
of the things you're doing today we're
just automating it for you
and then the way that this works is
where we're using
like text substitution in here to
substitute in the port and the host name
that redis
is running on um the reason why we
recommend doing this there's a long
dock that i wrote about it that's
amazing and you should read um
but the reason why we do stuff like this
like instead of hard-coding localhost is
you can't use localhost inside of docker
to refer to something else
inside of another docker container so
the actual connection string for redis
depends on who's asking which is an
incredibly subtle
thing to understand but for now just say
you know what we don't like hard coding
we're not going to hard code
the other thing that's going on here is
this postgres container
so when we initialize this postgres
container
we need to tell postgres it's going to
create a user for you by default called
postgres
and we need to tell it what password to
use for that user
and we can actually use the same sort of
like string substitution to say
like let's not repeat ourselves with
that password so
using i'm going to both set it as an
environment variable for the container
and feed it in here as my password
so i've now got postgres and redis as
part of this
part of this sort of service topology
and i'll go ahead and run
this and again when we do this
all of the services that are part of
this application are all going to be
offered
the connection strings for both of these
things through environment variables
so we take the approach by default of
assuming that everything's in a thai
yaml
are like buds with each other like their
friends you can control the visibility
of these things if you want to
you can be explicit about the
dependencies if you want to
we don't do it by default just because
it's complicated and maybe
you don't want that one or need that
level of complication in your life
i know i don't so we've got our services
running we've got our two containers and
we've got our three projects
if we go ahead and look at the redis
service
you can see there's log messages here
from redis and we can see the same for
postgres except my face is in the way
so we've got everything working here and
let's go ahead and give this application
a try
so the first thing i'm going to do is go
to my voting application and i'm going
to vote for dogs
of course because i'm a dog person and
then i'm going to go to the results
screen
and hopefully this should work so we can
see we've got one vote for dogs
that's pretty cool you can actually
change your vote if you're having a
really hard time deciding
i'm only doing it because of a demo i
changed it and it's cats
now i can change it back and it goes
back to dogs
so this is all kind of working as you'd
expect
if we go to the dashboard here we can
see some log messages from our worker
our worker is listening on a queue in
redis says got a new vote from redis
it's identifying me as a user via my
session
and then writing the results to postgres
and then it's sort of broadcast to the
to the results service and says hey by
the way the results have changed and
that's how that all comes together
so that's kind of neat we can see how
tai can manage dependencies
and how tai can get external
dependencies working and things like
that
let's think about how we can get this to
kubernetes because we've now got
redis and we've now got postgres and
things like that and so
it's one thing to deploy your code it's
another thing to say
i'm going to run postgres or i'm going
to run redis for you in in kubernetes
um because that's kind of complicated
and so we don't actually
um tie doesn't tai has support for
deploying
some containers if it's a container that
you built from source
so let's say you had the source code and
you told us to build a container for you
we have support for deploying that but
we don't by default sort of by
convention
we don't deploy containers for things
that you depend on
as pre-built images if that makes sense
the reason being that it's probably not
something you actually want to do
um like in my case like it could be it
could be helpful for a demo to deploy
postgres directly to kubernetes but like
i'm not actually going to go to
production that way because
i don't really know how to run postgres
in production
on kubernetes what i would opt for is
something like a hosted azure service or
hosted aws service if you like aws
hosted services are probably a simpler
way to go and so we're kind of optimized
for that right now
so when i do a tie deploy i'm doing an
interactive deploy again i've put in my
username
it's asking me for a connection string
for redis because the assumption is
redis lives somewhere out the outside of
the cluster
and that's pretty cool so i've actually
got i've actually
got a connection string for redis i need
to
bring up another window sorry
you will by the way um i have a
presentations repo where i put
all of my presentation content um for
for ndc as well as for other things so
um
you will be able to see all my
presentation materials later they're not
super up to date yet so here's my
this will not get checked in by the way
in case you're wondering and i will be
deleting these databases
but here's my very secure storage for my
connection strength so i've put in my
redis connection string
come back to my very did i do that wrong
no i did it right okay let's get my
redis connection string
here's my redis connection string cool
so i'm i'm just going to let that scroll
ah i'll let this let this deploy and not
leave it up on the screen for too long
um in case people feel like being spicy
but
i i know y'all are mature people so
there we've done a deployment it took
two minutes because i was talking over
it but
we've deployed all three of our
applications
and we've taken the configuration
information about redis and postgres
and put that in kubernetes secrets so if
i do a kubectl
get pods you can see my three pods are
running
if i do a cube ctl get secret
you can see that i've got a secret for
postgres
and a secret for redis so let's test
this out
and cube ctl port forward
service
i think it's called vote yeah it's
called vote 5000
to 80. hopefully this works i was having
a little bit of trouble with the redis
one last night
let's see i'll vote for dogs and then we
have to come back here
and let's do the same port forward but
let's do it for results
okay that's up refresh cancel that's not
what i want
yeah so you can see you can see my vote
and there are some existing votes here
because this is a
long lived postgrads that i've left
running so we've got some votes here
everything seems to be going okay the
other thing that i can do
is i can do cubectl logs
and let's look at the logs for our
worker and make sure that that's all
going okay
so yeah you can see we got the vote we
wrote it to postgrads other clients
updated
that's pretty cool that's working pretty
well one of the other things that i
might want to do here that's kind of
interesting is
the port forwarding aspect of this has
just got me like super fatigued right
like
it's kind of repetitive and slow and
lame like
i want to expose the voting service to
be publicly accessible so that people
can party on it
and tell me what they really think about
cats versus dogs right
um we've talked a little bit about
making production
like making development like production
let's see if we can leverage that where
did it go i don't know i nuked my vs
code
i knew to the vs code that i wanted
let's go ahead and do that
so one of the things that i would use if
i'm doing kubernetes is
i would create something called an
ingress we've mentioned before that
services are
internal by default in kubernetes if i
wanted to expose something to the public
what i would typically do is have an ip
address associated with my cluster
i'd have a bunch of dns records pointing
at that ip address
and then i'd have something like an
nginx proxy running there that's feeding
traffic to the different services
well i normally wouldn't be able to do
that sort of thing in my local
development
but with tai i can so i can actually add
an
ingress here to my tie.yaml
and then i'll here and i'll do tyron
and this is actually going to spin up a
local proxy it's not nginx in our case
by the way it's it's um
some of the guts of yarp um but it is
engine x when we deploy it
so in my list of services you can see
that i've actually got an ingress
so i've configured this ingress to
listen on port 8080
and forward all traffic to the voting
service now the listening port
is just basically just for local
development probably should be renamed
to like local development port or
something
but uh the idea with this is that
you wanna you want to be able to test
that your ingress is configured
correctly so you can see i got to the
voting
service which is what i wanted you want
to be able to test and interact with
your ingress in local development
because
if you're doing more complicated things
like path-based routing which with
this does support you want to be able to
test that you want to be able to make
that part of your development workflow
and there aren't a lot of tools out
there that can do that so we we felt
like that was pretty important
so let's go ahead and deploy this to
kubernetes
now since i'm deploying something that's
already running
um you'll notice that this time it's not
going to prompt me for any of those
connection strings or configuration data
it is going to prompt me for my registry
it's not going to prompt me for any of
that info
because uh it's already got that saved
so it creates those kubernetes secrets
and and backs them and you can see right
here
found existing secret binding production
redis secret so on
so it's gonna back those it's gonna back
those connection strings with a with a
kubernetes secret
and then the next time we deploy it's
going to use that same thing
now in order to sort of save time here i
have pre-deployed an ingress controller
so if we do
ctl get pods a
you can see that there's an nginx
ingress engine x namespace with some
pods running in it or one one running in
it so i have
already deployed engine x um ty can do
that for you
not doing it because it takes about 45
seconds for it to start um
there is a tutorial for ingress that
sort of explains how this stuff works
and walks you through all the concepts
and really gives a good explanation of
it
if you're curious about it um but in
order to save your time i've not done
that
so the way that i would get that ingress
we're going to do a cube ctl
get service i need to do dash a for all
and we can see that i've got this ip
address
so this ip address 52 143
84 28 let's go to it
i can cast my vote and i would invite
all of y'all
to go 52 143 84
28 somebody wants to paste that in the
chat for me
you feel free to go hit that and and
and express yourself and i'm going to
i'm going to port forward the voting
service the results service
and we can see we can see some of the
votes coming in
hopefully so this will be
localhost 5000.
so we've got seven for dogs so i know
some of you are doing it because i can
see that this is higher
the cat people are taking over and the
battle the battle is
is joined i don't know why i chose these
terrible colors this is really
brown and brown and light green it's
terrible so
we've created an ingress we've made
something publicly exposed to the
internet
um we've shown that we can we can use
containers and dependencies for local
development
and we can deploy an app with ingress to
the cluster and actually see something
public so
we're starting to aim towards towards
towards doing a fairly complete end to
end here
i'm going to go ahead and i'll go ahead
and leave that up
um because i don't think i'm using
kubernetes for anything else today
so let me jump back to my slides and
we'll talk a little bit more
so what we saw we saw a multi-project
multi-service oriented development
environment
where you can you can work on more than
one at a time
we saw some really simple patterns
around service discovery and how you
identify and manage dependencies we saw
using dependencies
in docker and then like really easily
putting your own stuff in docker or
putting your own stuff in kubernetes
those are some of the basic things that
tai can do for you
i want to shift gears a little bit and
talk about diagnostics because
diagnostics is a
is a is a con is a topic that's very
near and dear to my heart
basically the problem is the more
services you have the more problems you
have
i like to say that you know what used to
be a method call is now an http request
or a message queue message
right so you're used to something
failing and seeing a call stack
and now something fails in another
service at some point in the future
or maybe it doesn't get to the other
service which is the worst feeling
you send an http request and it seems
like it's a success
and it fails in some other boundary so
we need good diagnostics features
for cloud native applications otherwise
we're just sort of blind
and the the way that i sort of think
about these topics is broken into three
categories
there's logs how do we combine all the
logs that you have and make it easy for
you to query across them
there's metrics how do we look at what's
going on on your computers
and what's going on inside your
application and then there's distributed
tracing which is
how do we stitch together events and
transactions and communication across
different parts of your application that
are not part of the same code base
or even on the same same machine so
to that end i've got an app that we're
going to use as a sample for diagnostics
um we're not going to spend a lot of
time talking through the app
or the code or anything like that if
you've done the blazer workshop which i
believe the blazer workshop has been
taught at this conference
by some friends of mine this is
basically a microservices version of the
blazer workshop using
heavy use of grpc so i'll share the link
for that
source code later and you can check that
out if you're interested
and we're going to talk about some
diagnostics functionality with that and
the tie
the sort of tie angle to this so let's
go back to
some demos and i'm going to let's do
this
i've got another repo here i'm going to
bring up vs code
and then i'm going to immediately do a
tie run and i'll start talking over this
while that's starting up so there's a
lot of projects here
um reason why there's a lot of projects
is because the way the blazer workshop
is taught we teach you to
create projects for blazer so don't
worry about that
but let's look at the thai.yaml so the
thai.yaml is kind of interesting because
we've got
in ingress here we've got our services
we've got three databases my friend
glenn helped me put this together for an
earlier uh demo
we've got three databases in this case
we're using sql server
and this is these are custom made as the
glenn built but they're based on sql
server
and we've got a redis here so there are
three databases
a reddit five projects five five like
web apps
and ingress and then these extensions
so the extensions are kind of neat we've
got an extension for zipkin
an extension for elastic or for elastic
stack
formerly known as elk zipkin is a fairly
popular and well-known distributed
tracing
database distributed tracing dashboard
jager is another one which we don't have
direct support for but we do
we do have zipkin and we could add
jaeger at some point
elasticstack is a popular like log
search aggregation
thing built on elasticsearch
and kibana so the reason why i've been
explaining all this
is this is a massive amount of stuff to
start up in particular
elasticsearch takes a very long time to
start up
and um these sql servers use kind of a
massive amount of resources but
true to doing microservices each service
has its
database which is why there's so many so
i think we've kind of got everything
going here
we'll check in we'll check in on elastic
before we
do anything and make sure that that's
working
so my dashboard is starting and it's
being slow
running running webex and all this stuff
together i've got a new macbook and it's
still
it's still kind of a lot um let's check
in on
elastic and make sure that that's
working okay
so we are working here great so let's
run through the app and just do
something so i'll go ahead and go to our
ingress so we're loading up the blazing
blazing pizza app
it's gonna i'm already signed in because
dedication is fake
um in this version of the demo and uh
let's go ahead and let's put together a
pizza
now it is it is like 9 30 where i
am so i think the most appropriate pizza
for morning is probably a classic
pepperoni
um extra large with uh fresh baked
scones because this is breakfast time
so let's go ahead i'm going to move my
face
let's go ahead and order that it's in
british this is
this is all the all the currency and
everything here is in british because
this is a london-based
uh pizzeria but they do deliver
internationally
so i would love to get notifications
which won't work because i'm in
uh do not disturb mode and i'm gonna
very carefully enter my
uh my contact information here for the
delivery they do contact this
contactless delivery which is great they
send you a browser notification
and just leave the pizza on the steps
then you come out and get it so
i'm not actually here i'm in seattle by
the way i'm not at the house of
parliament
in london but anyway i've placed my
pizza order
and it's communicating with these
different services we've got an order
service we've got a delivery service
we've got a
toppings or sort of inventory service
which is where that pizza info comes
from
and then my pizza goes out for delivery
and it's on it's on its way via drone
from london to my location uh so let's
we we said that this was about
diagnostics let's diagnose some
diagnostics
so i'll open up zip can now and zipkin
i mentioned is a distributed tracing
dashboard and so if i do a search
here and do this search here you see a
bunch of traces
and you should think about traces in
zipkin
as like this is an end to end of a
request
this is a request that came in and
everything else that that request did
so i'll pick this one which was i think
getting the
like order status so a request
let's let's talk through this a request
came in
to the front end and then the front end
made a grpc call to the order service so
this is
this is a data tracing data created by
http client this is tracing data created
by asp.net core
this is tracing data created by http
client so you can see that it's front
end
and it's got a url of another service
and that's a very grpc looking url if
you haven't
looked at grpc before and then it goes
to the order service this is created by
asp.net core
the order service did something and
returned some data um the front-end
service then
after doing that it gives us a timeline
view said
okay let's contact the delivery service
and made a call to the delivery service
and sort of the same thing happen
so you can see the end-to-end process of
servicing this request and you could
imagine that this would get better over
time like there
there are ways to plug in redis to this
which i haven't done in the
example but you could also imagine a way
to plug in sql server to this you could
see
my sql server query show up here as well
which would be really cool
and that's sort of what distributed
tracing does for you
so the next thing i'll do is i'm going
to take this trace id and the trace id
you can think of
as sort of the identifier for the full
end-to-end request
now asp.net core and http client have
code
built in that flow those things across
requests for you
so you don't have to do this sort of
like manual
manual propagation of those things
manual management of headers
now this is my elastic dashboard in
cabana
and this has collected all of the logs
of everything so i can now do queries
across all the logs of everything that i
have
and it remembers what i like to do last
time which is
i i want the message i want the trace id
and i want the application that was
involved
and then let's go ahead and i'm going to
going to do a filter
i don't know what filter by type is oh
this is the one i want i'll do a filter
and i'm going to filter on the trace id
so i grab that trace id from my zip can
and i'm going to save it here
and hopefully i chose a good one and you
can see i've got
log messages here i've got a consistent
view of all the log messages across the
front end
the order service the front end the
order service
and i don't know why i don't have the
delivery service here i kind of expect
that but i don't see it
i have seen issues with this in the
local configuration where it seems like
events and logs are being dropped
and it might be due to just slow uh i'm
not totally sure
because it's a kind of a crush to run
all these things on my machine
especially elastic
so anyway sort of
unpacking what we've seen here you can
have a request that failed
you can have a you can get the trace id
you can see where in the system it
failed you can take that trace id
back here and you can see all the log
messages across all the services
that participated in that transaction
and have this nice sort of query
dashboard so if you've ever wondered
about structured logging
and why asp.net logging sort of is the
way it is with key value pairs instead
of a string dot format
well it's this right all these fields
are searchable
so we get the name of the controller
action that was being executed
we get the amount of time taken in the
request
and a whole bunch of other information
this this came from mvc
we had a whole bunch of other
information here and this is all
queryable by systems like this
and they're really powerful when you
combine distributed tracing
with logging into one big happy thing
now
we haven't talked about how this works
and i think that that's probably the
best part here
so i've got these two extensions here
which is probably not surprising that
tai is starting and running these things
for you when you put them as an
extensions
but the other thing that this is doing
is it's wiring up
our collector to send the data to these
things
so we use something in donet called
event pipe which is
pretty new i think it was new in 3.0 and
it's what powers tools like donet
counters
and it's what power is the thai
dashboard so if you've wondered about
how the log collection works for the
thai dashboard or how the metrics
collection works for the thai dashboard
any net process you can effectively
attach to it and get a stream of
diagnostics information
that stream of diagnostics information
includes
all of this and all of this
if you know how to ask for it and you
know how to put it together
so tai can without any changes to your
application without any sdks
or configuration that sits inside your
app
we can attach to your process we can get
all that information and we can export
it for you so that you don't have to do
it
we can do the same thing with metrics we
haven't implemented that yet
there's probably some big gaps to fill
around metrics because
the matrix collection packages that
people have written for
metrics collection for like prometheus
are very very good
so we have some gaps to fill there which
is why we're not talking about metrics
too
so that's kind of that in a nutshell
i've got a couple slides that sort of
unpack this in a little bit more detail
i'll get my face out of the way
just i don't know there's got to be some
there's got to be some
physical law that describes how oh i i
know what i need to do i need to shut
this down because this is using a huge
amount of memory
um it's got to be some physical law
about how your face is always in the way
and one of these calls of the button you
need
so when we do this in production we can
deploy to kubernetes and we can do the
same thing
what we actually do in kubernetes and
i'm not going to show it today just
because of time is you can we deploy
what's called a sidecar in your pods
so we can run our collector in a
separate process next to your
application
and then we can forward all that data or
we can exfiltrate all that data
for you so you don't have to put any
code in your application
you don't have to configure anything in
your application to get these nice
features
so that's kind of the end to end of
where we are
with tai um i think we're kind of
about at time i haven't seen i haven't
seen anybody
really like having a lot of questions or
anything like that
but if you've got if you've got
questions i'd be happy to answer them
i'm going to quickly run through some of
my own q a
because i've answered many questions
about tai in the past
and so i've chosen the good ones to kind
of snipe you guys
so what does it mean the ties in
experiment it means that
we have an uncertain future for what
we're building and what we're doing here
we see this as a sort of two-way
collaboration
and we really don't know like we really
don't
have a plan yet as far as what the
future is of what we're doing with tai
it might be the case that all the
technology and all the investments in
thai
get turned into like other things
you could imagine that docker building
functionality getting
just baked into the sdk you could
imagine the multi-launch multi-debug
dashboard kind of functionality baking
into vs code or
visual studio so we don't know the
ultimate destination
we're just sort of trying to learn as
much as we can about what people
really want and what they're like what
adds value what makes your life better
guillaume asks uh guillerm asks adding
thai to an existing project
is an easy process i would say that it's
the easiest process
because the things that the only thing
that tai really wants
in your project is there's one method
to read like urls right there's
there's some opinionated use of
configuration but you've already got
configuration
i would say that thai is something you
use to automate your process rather than
add to
your process unless you're talking about
a development process or a
like devops process in which case you
know tell me more
so i would say if you're already if
you're already doing.net
today like it's one of the easiest
things that you could start
using that will probably really give you
a boost in terms of your productivity
if you don't think that it helps you i'm
really interested to know
um what you're doing that makes you so
satisfied with your development workflow
so who's this for ties for developers
we do some publishing and we do some
kubernetes stuff
but tai is a developer oriented
developer focused tools
i think for a lot of people they look at
the kubernetes functionality and they
say
wow i didn't know i could do kubernetes
that's kind of cool and they move on
with their life or they use it as like a
learning tool for kubernetes
i think for a lot of people on the other
end that are very experienced with
devops and kubernetes
would say you know i've already solved
these problems it doesn't add a lot to
me
i think that the deployment in
kubernetes aspects of tai is the part
that's like really
experimental so we're looking for
feedback there to be honest like we're
looking for
ideas and we're looking for feedback
about you know i would use this i
wouldn't use this
and here's why to help shape future
direction
i think there's a spectrum that people
fall on as far as their organizational
maturity
with devops and their organizational
maturity with those
those practices so you can sort of think
of what you've seen today
as like right click publish but for uh
but for kubernetes um which there aren't
a lot of examples of in the industry
we do we do have the idea that something
like tai could be part of a git ops
workflow
but we haven't really done the work to
prove that out yet
it does tai does play with things like
versioning so if you have a versioning
scheme set up for your projects already
that's ms build based
tai can already work with that all
because my stuff was demos everything
was 100 but thai can already
work with those kinds of things it only
does kubernetes can it do other things
so i really like the idea that we would
be able to do other things
kubernetes is kubernetes is where we
started i think for a variety of reasons
namely that we wanted to expose dot-net
developers to kubernetes
the more we've talked to down at
developers about kubernetes
the more we found pockets of people who
are being very successful very quietly
which has been interesting for us to
talk to and to learn from
you might have access to kubernetes and
if you don't you can easily get access
you can run it locally
with mini cube or something like that
and so it's a good way to get your feet
wet in this technology if you're new to
it
and then lastly kubernetes is powerful
enough for us to do really powerful
stuff like
diagnostic sidecars and ingresses and
things um
i think we're interested in ideas about
where else we could do publishing and
deployment
but without turning tai into an azure
specific tool specifically
despite the fact that i now work on
azure um why did we build this
uh that's actually one of the most most
favorite questions that a lot of people
have
i think we're looking in this the
microservices
and back-end development space and
saying what can we add here
and our frameworks are fairly mature uh
we hear success stories and happy
stories from users every day about
how they're thrilled with the platform
or they're thrilled with the latest
upgrade
and the truth is like we can't just keep
churning stuff we can't just keep
changing stuff um
there's a there's a cool down period
after doing like a dramatic change
something and so we can't just keep
tweaking and changing and modifying and
updating
it becomes a treadmill after a while so
we're looking for other ways to add
value
turns out very few people are happy with
their dev productivity for microservices
there aren't a lot of tools that solve
it really well so some stuff that's
unique about tai
is first of all the philosophy of being
a tool that
goes through the existing process with
you you start from the moment you decide
to write code
and tai continues to live with you until
you've got something fully automated
with the ci cd system
that's the sort of vision for it there
aren't a lot of tools that try to solve
that
most tools try to focus on doing one
thing well we're trying to do everything
pretty well
and we also think that there's a lot of
value out of building something
dotnet focused for download developers
that is to say it's not uh that is not
to say that everything has to be a.net
project
we immediately heard from a lot of
people when we started working on thai
that they wanted they wanted support for
non-dotnet projects
because everybody out there has got like
one angular app
and five asp.net backends so
we do support building and publishing
sort of arbitrary docker images as well
as donna projects from thai which is a
fairly recent
edition so that's the end
you can find me on twitter if you want
um these materials will be uploaded to
my presentations repo
at some point um and thanks everybody
for your attention
i'll probably be hanging around i'll
probably be hanging around the
conference for
a couple more minutes if people have
that they want to ask or things that
they want to say
but other than that thanks for your
attention and have a have a great
rest of the conference